"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT WHERE
WE FOCUS ON THE CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY.
LEDINGHAM SOCIAL MEDIA, QUEEN OF
THE CLAP FACT, A MODERN ART
INSTALLATION DEMEANS THE FIRST
DAUGHTER, AND 10-YEAR-OLD CUB
SCOUT TAKING A KNEE.
JOINING US WITH ALL THE DETAILS,
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLING AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK, ALMOST OUT, "WELL
WILDER."
PELOSI DID HER VERY BEST TO
STEAL THE PRESIDENTS VENDOR LAST
NIGHT.
BUT IT'S THE CLAPPED FACT THAT
IT'S GETTING ALL THE ATTENTION.
WE ARE HITTING
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO HEAR ON
VOX.
>> ANYONE HE WANTS A STATE OF
THE UNION AND IS FAMILIAR WITH
SPEAKER PELOSI'S ATTEMPTS TO
STEAL THE FOCUS ALL EVENING,
REALIZED THAT SHE HAS PERFECTED
THE ART OF SUBTLE CONTEMPT.
MAYBE SHE JUST NEEDS SOME FIX-IT
END.
WHATEVER THE CASE, SHE WAS
GNAWING ON SOMETHING IN HER
MOUTH ALL EVENING.
A LOZENGE, BEEF JERKY, WE MAY
NEVER KNOW?
>> Laura: BEEF JERKY!
[LAUGHS]
>> SHE PULLED OUT WHAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN A LARGE MENU AND SHE
LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS TRYING TO
DECIDE WHETHER TO HAVE THEIR
FROG WHILE OR THE PEA SOUP OR
MAYBE SHE'S READING OBAMACARE
OBAMACARE.
NOW NANCY PELOSI'S MOUTH TAKE
SEEMS TO BE CATCHING.
THIS IS KAMALA HARRIS, LAURA,
REACTING TO THE PRESIDENT CALLS
TO PUT TELL COYOTES AT A
BUSINESS AT THE BORDER.
LOOK AT HER MOUTH.
SHE'S GOT THEM OUT TO
>> Laura: IT'S OF NOXIOUS.
>> IS SPREADING.
NOTHING CAUGHT THE ATTENTION OF
DEMOCRATS AT THIS MOMENT AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION, BEING CALLED
THE NANCY CLAP BACK.
WATCH.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU SEE, IT IS THIS EXTENDED
SHOULDER.
THEY ARE READING A LOT INTO
THIS.
PELOSI'S DAUGHTER CHRISTINE
SAYS, THAT CLAPPED FACT TOOK ME
BACK TO THE TEEN YEARS.
SHE KNOWS, AND SHE KNOWS THAT
YOU KNOW, AND FRANKLY, SHE'S
DISAPPOINTED THAT YOU THOUGHT IT
WOULD WORK.
SHE WILL CLAP FOR YOU.
>> Laura: WHY DO WE CARE ABOUT
WHAT CHRISTINE PELOSI -- THE
WALK DOWN MEMORY LANE WITH
MOMMY?
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
>> Laura: SHE WAS A SCHOOL
DIVISION AND IS COOL TO NOW.
>> "THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD AN
ARTICLE ABOUT THIS, "THE
EXQUISITE SHADE OF DEMOCRATS
NANCY PELOSI'S APPLAUSE."
THEY ARE DESPERATE.
THE OTHER POINT, WHEN STACEY
ABRAMS IS YOUR MOUTH PLEASE COME
AND NANCY PELOSI CLAPPING SEEMS
LIKE MARIA CALLAS AND THE LAST
ACT OF "HOSTILE."
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR HELP.
SOMETHING THEY CAN -- A BIT OF
PERFORMANCE ART THEY CAN LATCH
ONTO.
>> Laura: I COULD NOT SLEEP
LAST NIGHT, ABSOLUTELY DURING
THE SHOW, I KEPT THINKING OF
THAT COMMERCIAL.
>> WHAT WAS THAT?
>> KENT FRENCH AS THE
WORLD-CLASS CLAPPER.
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TO
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TG
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TW
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TC
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TL
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TA
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TS
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED TD
WITH THE CLAPPER, I ONLY NEED T.
>> CLAP ON, CLAP OFF.
>> CLAP THINGS ON, CLAP THINGS
OFF.
>> Laura: WHEN THEY LOSE THE
MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE OF 2020,
SHE CAN BE THE NEW CLAP ON --
>> IT MAY NOT BE -- SHE MAY HAVE
BEEN OSTEOPOROSIS OR SOMETHING,
JUST CLAPPING.
ANYWAY, LAURA, A NEW EXHIBIT --
>> Laura: ART EXHIBIT.
CONTEMPORARY.
>> JUST OPENED IN WASHINGTON.
IT'S CALLED IVANKA VACUUMING.
IVANKA TRUMP LOOK-ALIKE IS IN A
GALLERY, AND PATRONS ARE INVITED
TO THROW CRUMBS AT HER, TRASH,
THAT SHE WILL VACUUM UP.
THE GALLERY SAYS, "IVANKA
VACUUMING IS SIMULTANEOUSLY A
VISUAL CELEBRATION OF A
CONTEMPORARY FEMININE ICON, A
PORTRAIT OF OUR OWN RELATIONSHIP
TO THAT FIGURE, AND A
QUESTIONING OF OUR COMPLICITY IN
HER ROLE PLAYING."
YOU KNOW WHAT I DISCOVERED ABOUT
THIS CULTURAL GROUP PUTTING THIS
ON?
NOT ONLY IS IT SEXIST AND
MISOGYNIST, THIS GROUP IS
TAXPAYER-FUNDED.
THEY GET $120,000 IN COVERALL
FUNDING IN 2016.
IMAGINE IF THEY PUT
MICHELLE OBAMA AND PEOPLE WERE
ENCOURAGED WITH HER A PRODUCE AT
HER IN A GARDEN OR LET'S SAY
HILLARY CLINTON, WHERE YOU
THROUGH EMAIL SERVERS AT HER,
AND SHE PICKS THEM UP.
THAT WILL BE SEEN AS WHAT IT
SAYS, SEXIST, MISOGYNIST, AND
INHUMAN.
THIS IS REALLY --
>> Laura: I WAS NEVER BIG INTO
PERFORMANCE ARTS.
>> ME EITHER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: IT'S ALWAYS LIKE,
THERE IS A WOMAN WITH A RED DOT
ON THE WALL, AND SHE STARES AT
IT.
>> HOW WAS A WOMAN VACUUMING
ART?
THIS IS CALLED DOMESTIC CHORES.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS.
>> Laura: IT'S IDIOTIC.
THEY DID IT FOR MICHELLE, THEY
WOULD BE PROTESTS OUT FRONT.
NOW FINALLY, A CUB SCOUT -- MY
KIDS ARE IN CUB SCOUTS, SEE THEM
RIGHT THERE, CUTIE, HE TOOK A
KNEE AT A CITY COUNCIL MEETING
IN NORTH CAROLINA DURING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
LOCAL MEDIA PICKED UP ON MY
STORY.
THE KID AND HIS FATHER EXPLAINED
THE STUNTS THIS WAY.
>> WHAT I DID WAS TAKE ANY
AGAINST RACIAL DISCRIMINATION,
WHICH IS BASICALLY WHAT PEOPLE
ARE BEING TAUGHT OTHER PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT COLORS.
>> WHEN I DID IT, I WAS REALLY
SURPRISED AND ALSO REALLY PROUD
OF HIM.
>> THE FATHER DISCUSSED THIS
WITH HIM BEFOREHAND.
HE SAYS -- THE CITY COUNCIL
SAID, I'M GLAD THAT HE EXERCISED
HIS CONSCIENCE.
THIS IS NOT CONSCIENCE, THIS IS
PROPAGANDA AND POLITICAL CHILD
ABUSE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK KIDS LIKE
THAT?
>> HE'S NOT AN NFL PLAYER, NO
REASON FOR HIM TO NEIL.
HE WANTS TO PROTEST, HELP POOR
PEOPLE OR BETTER YET, TAKE YOUR
CUB SCOUT TROOP WOULD GO TO THE
INNER-CITY.
>> Laura: I THINK A LOT OF
VETERANS I SAW COMMENTING --
>> THEY WERE NOT HAPPY.
>> Laura: THEY WERE LIKE HIM I
WAS AN EAGLE SCOUT, OUR WHOLE